[Musique]
ils vont très bon jour bonjour bonjour à
tous les auditeurs et une petite pensée
particulière pour tous les bas rhinois
alors vous avez 50 ans vous êtes la
première adjointe du maire du marin vous
allez conduire la liste de l'union
démocratique populaire pour le renouveau
du marin et vous avez été adoubé par le
maire sortant qui ne se représente pas
aux d'offres désirer qu'est ce qui vous
motive qu'est ce qui vous pousse à vous
présenter qu'est ce qui me pousse bien
tout simplement parce que j'y suis
depuis bientôt douze ans que j'ai appris
aux côtés de deux équipes différentes
2008 et 2015 équipe de 2008 et l'équipe
de 2014 et que le marin c'est une grande
belle ville qui bouge énormément et nous
avons beaucoup de projets des projets
qui avancent pour certains très vite
d'autres plus ou moins vite et donc les
le challenge le défi est beau voilà mon
contexte difficile
rodolphe désiré mises en examen dans la
sphère de karen antilles
la campagne sera difficile c'est un
point noir fardeau non du tout du tout
il convient de dire que bien évidemment
on sait tous ceux et vous venez de le
dire ce qui se passe sur le marin mais
c'est une situation qui ma foi nous
permet aussi
de mettre à plat beaucoup de choses de
discuter aussi avec les professionnels
qui ne comprennent pas certaines un
système et pour aussi gardien qui ne
comprenaient pas que c'était un an que
c'est un outil de la collectivité donc
un outil municipal quand je parle des
dsp que ce soit sur le carénage ou le
port de plaisance et non la situation
elle doit être noir dans bien des
endroits maintenant c'est une prise de
responsabilité et non ça ne me fait pas
peur voilà c'est fait mais quand même
c'est ça rend la campagne plus difficile
pas plus qu'à gérer parce que c'est ça
donne à vous à vos adversaires des
arguments enfin c'est là où il aurait
cherché toutes sortes d'arguments et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas peut-être pas
sur cela qu'ils s'appuient le plus donc
quand voilà la campagne on m'a prévenu
j'ai tout j'ai eu l'occasion ici même de
le dire la campagne elle sera ce qu'elle
sera nous on défendra un programme on
continuera à travailler puisque je suis
quand même élu de la majorité est
première adjointe jusqu'en 2020 donc je
continue mon travail jusque-là tout en
rencontrant les uns et les autres avec
une belle équipe autour de moi et
rien ne m'empêche de continuer
aujourd'hui et nous sont faits nous
sommes fermes dans nos positions
le marin une ville divisée quand on voit
le conseil municipal
on sait que vous êtes candidate mais on
sait que le deuxième adjoint soutiens
quelqu'un d'autre et qu'il y sera que
cette personne se serait dit serez vous
serez face à face le marais visé le
marin on est en période électorale donc
forcément il ya des divisions partout je
pense que c'est n'est vraiment pas
quelque chose de nouveau et je pense
qu'il faille pas sata il faut pas
s'attarder là-dessus savoir ce sont des
débats ma foi qui ne nous apporte pas
grand-chose qui font pas progresser
lamartine alors j'ai envie de dire que
le sort s'acharne sur eux sur la commune
puisque vous n'avez pas a perdu
l'organisation de la mini-transat alors
qu'elle était arrivée il ya quelques
mois ici j'étais tellement fâché comme
j'ai appris ça en fait non ça se passe
pas comme ça il ya une organisation qui
est un groupe organisateur qui était le
comité rochelais d'accord qui a
travaillé avec la classe mini qui
s'occupe de l'organisation purement de
la course donc nous avions répondu un
marché donc qui intégrait la rochelle
comme organisateur las palmas et nous en
ville d'arrivée est en fait la rochelle
n'a pas eu le marché ce sont les sables
d'olonne et forcément nous faisant
partie du marché rochelais on n'a pas
illuminé par le marin qui n'a pas eu
l'organisation très bien alors on va
parler du de votre programme quels sont
les grands axes de votre programme
alors quand on part en continuité et il
s'agit bien évidemment de continuer un
certain travail des dossiers qui sont
déjà inscrits pour lesquels on travaille
depuis de nombreuses années de nombreux
mois sur notamment pour certains des
études ou d'autres où on a commencé
certains travaux donc ça c'est de la
continuité c'est de la continuité dans
le travail aussi avec les services de
l'état
1 quel qu'il soit parce que on ne bâtit
pas on ne structure pas on ne développe
pas économiquement si on ne travaille
pas avec ses partenaires quand une
vieille toujours tournée vers la mer
nous n'avons alors il faut bien voir que
l'analyse c'est que quand la mer
en tout ce qui a été valorisée à sion de
la mer a été faite la valorisation de
l'intérieur aussi a été fait donc ça a
été un travail pour stopper l'exode
rural faire en sorte que l'économie
durable reviennent donc dans un même
temps on a signé une convention avec un
groupement européen on dit ça on
travaille donc justement avec bruxelles
là dessus avec l'espace sud notamment et
la ctm et on travaille sur comment
continuer à faire le lien entre la mer
et la terre il ne s'agit pas d'être
contre eux mais les termes et bien faire
le lien even prins je vous remercie
je vous en prie à très bientôt